[Musique]
personne n'est prêt à payer pour publier
les cris valide israël
aujourd'hui j'ai plusieurs mois de loyer
à payer et mon chat est malade il est 4
heures de l'après midi et vous êtes
saoul je suis presque pas ce qu'est la
même chose
ma suggestion c'est que tu te bouges les
fesses et que tu trouves un autre moyen
de gagner ta vie
j'ai trouvé cette jolie lettre signée
qui semble authentique fanny bryce une
de mes préférées c'est sûr que je
pourrai tirer beaucoup de celles ci par
hasard je me suis mise dans une position
de nature délictueuse dans quelques unes
d'activités illégales qui a bien pu
tomber à part l'attentât au bon goût
vestimentaire modifie des lettres
écrites par de prestigieux écrit un bon
ça ce n'est pas rien donnez moi votre
prix
qu'est ce qu'on va faire on va flamber
faire du shopping se soulever quelques
questions sur la dernière lettre que je
vois votre nom est désormais sur une
liste
du pastiche d'autres écrivains ce ne
sont pas les lettres de nice règles
d'achat il ya pas mal de faux qui tourne
ces derniers temps je me suis dit c'est
une très belle en alerte
tu as aussi me fallait à tout prix c'est
moi faut vous attendre à passer quelques
temps derrière les barreaux pas dire que
j'adresse mes à bien des égards cette
période c'est la meilleure de ma vie
[Musique]